ah j'ai retrouvé la farce avec l'arc
généalogie 1 2 3 4 8 9 9 ans semblait
manie des eaux consommées tepa il y en
avait quand même les gosses pour
comprendre les dynamiques démographiques
à l'oeuvre au sein des différentes
populations du monde
les démographes ont proposé un modèle
celui de la transition démographique
dans cette vidéo je vous propose de
découvrir ce modèle mais tout de suite
le générique génériques
[Musique]
le modèle de la transition démographique
bien qu'il soit parfois remis en
question est utilisé par toutes les
grandes organisations internationales
pour comprendre comment les populations
vont évoluer dans le futur
qu'est ce que la transition
démographique la transition
démographique est un modèle qui permet
de comprendre le passage d'une
démographie traditionnelle a eu un
régime démographique moderne entre le
régime démographique traditionnel et le
régime démographique moderne il y à un
important accroissement de la population
un boom démographique
quels sont les quatre phases la
transition démographique au régime
démographique traditionnels le taux de
mortalité est le taux de natalité sont
relativement parallèle et constant mais
à des niveaux très élevés il peut y
avoir également des pics de mortalité
qui correspondent aux grandes épidémies
aux familles ou aux guerres pour des
raisons sociétales économiques
politiques la population va rentrer dans
la transition démographique
on aura tout d'abord la première phase
de la transition démographique qui
correspond à une diminution importante
du taux de mortalité dans la deuxième
phase la transition démographique la
natalité se met à baisser la population
n'a plus besoin de procréer pour assurer
sa descendance
il ya donc un décalage entre la
diminution du taux de mortalité d'une
part et du taux de natalité
d'autre part boom démographique enfin
lorsque la population arrive au stade de
la démographie moderne et bien les taux
de mortalité et de natalité arrive à un
équilibre et la population ne demandent
plus de manière démesurée
cette vidéo est terminée j'espère
qu'elle vous aura permis de comprendre
ce qu'était la transition démographique
ce n'est qu'un modèle évidemment si vous
faites des études plus poussées sur ces
terrains là et bien il faudra dépasser
ce modèle qui est parfois un peu
réducteur mais
dans le cadre du coup de géographie en
cinquième et en sixième année c'est un
modèle qui peut nous être très utile
je vous remercie et je vous dis à très
bientôt
[Musique]